I drive down the road I stop at a
homeless facility I survey three guys
I'm a mile down the road like looking
back on I think what were you thinking
but there were three three homeless guys
that were in their early 30s and they
were they were all Caucasian that's hard
to find so trust me I've looked spent
hours before track finding these guys so
that's like the the the golden thing
you're looking for is white guys in
their 30s right cuz that's I was in my
30s that I wasn't an old man like I am
now so I I survey them I drive straight
to Nashville yeah get to
Nashville drive through an area called
uh Green
Hills
um well I first I when I got to
Nashville I stayed the night and the
next day I went into I'm going to say up
a UPS Store it was actually a Kinko
there used to be they used to be called
Kinkos but I remember Kinkos they got
bought by um FedEx I feel like oh is it
FedEx FedEx okay then it was a FedEx
store so I go in there and you give them
like 50 bucks or something or 20 bucks
or something they' give you like a 100
business cards so I get a I go get a a
burn a phone number a burner phone I go
in there I make up oh I call and get a
phone number from HQ the local HQ I come
up with the name manufactured funding
group I've got two phone numbers I get
business cards made with a name one of
the guys name that I surveyed was um uh
his his actual name was um Joseph Marian
Carter Jr I went by Carter so I get
business cards made of Joseph
Carter I then drive through Green Hills
took him like an hour uh to get the card
so I'm driving through Green Hills I'm
planning on going to an apartment but
I'm still I don't have an idea I don't
have anything like I'm I'm wondering how
what am I going to do how am I going to
get a place to stay I'm going to stay in
a hotel like what am I doing I'm I'm
using an an ID that the cops are looking
for so as I'm driving trying to find the
this big apartment complex there's a guy
putting a sign in the front yard of like
a townhouse M cuz several tow houses and
I probably in his 60s I pull in jump out
of the car and I said hey is that this
for rent he said yes it is I said oh
okay uh yeah can I see it sure I go in
check it out come back downstairs it's
perfect said listen I uh you know I work
for a company you know manufactured
funding group boom handam thing I said I
I've been in in uh uh Europe
for the last I forget what I said I said
England I had some little town outside
of London in you know whatever Dexter
you know London for the past 5 years I
don't really have any any credit but I
said I I can put down a double the
security deposit or you know whatever
you need here's my business card he
looked at me and he looked at my car and
he
goes you look like an honest young man
he said I'll uh I'll take the first
month's rent and a and a deposit mhm and
he said now go get a leash right now and
I said okay and I said oh okay filled
out a leash right then gave me the keys
like nice like very trusting in in in
that town well oh yeah but there must
have been also something about you
you're just I mean I don't got a nice
car I know you're going to get a lot of
comments that say White Privilege but
that's that's what you're I think the
Charisma has something to do with it
yeah um well I so he gave I appreciate
that so he gave me
Keys listen I ordered all
of all of uh Joseph Carter's Vital
Information right like all of his uh
birth certificate social security C
everything uh that night MH from like a
Kinkos or some of the I forget where but
from some one of these places I went
online you could go online back then
right like there wasn't Wi-Fi everywhere
so I order the stuff it shows up a
couple days later I take that
information I I go and I get a driver's
license we're about within like seven or
eight days I've got a driver's license
in his name mhm I get in that car U
Michael Eckert's car I drive it all the
way back to Nashville I leave it in
long-term parking get on a plane fly
back to
Nashville go in and buy myself a brand
new car was brand new it was a couple
years old but from like CarMax MH when
within 2 weeks I am completely 100% set
up I start dating for 3 4 months that
gets really boring and uh where where
again in Nashville you said Nashville
okay got it so I started dating a bunch
of chicks and then I end up meeting this
one girl by the way are you lonely here
cuz you're on on the run is that man
listen being I'm telling you right now
being on the Run was the best part of my
life really everybody you know how all
these guys say it was horrible and I was
I was so concerned and looking over my
shoulder and it wasn't I wasn't keep in
mind I I've gotten I've gotten five or
six traffic tickets while on the run I
went to traffic school as someone else I
got so many traffic tickets in his name
I went to traffic school as him like if
I got a pulled over like I'm not
concerned so your confidence just was
and I'm I'm driving driving a vehicle in
the name of the driver's license that I
have that was issued by that state full
coverage insurance I'm not an idiot I'm
not driving around a stolen car with a
broken tail light and a body in the
trunk like I'm covered like I'm not
concerned about the local cops uh plus
you're going to Starbucks sipping your
coffee and driving away from uh US
Marshall right that was you could start
believing that it's impossible to catch
you that is exactly what it is it's it's
every time I just kept getting more and
more emboldened more and more cocky
arrogant like they're not going to catch
I'm too good you know which is great
until they catch you yeah and
so I I meet a girl named Amanda Gardner
well what I end up doing is keep mind
I've only got 100,000 or so so I go and
I start buying houses in the area in
this area called JC Napier next to it's
just close to downtown and I buy these
houses and I start record I buy them for
like 60 70,000 and I record the sales at
210 190 one 2 205 that sort of thing
same thing and I refinance the house as
I start pulling out
money I meet this girl uh Amanda Garder
she we hit it off within a few month
she's moved in to we move into a house
in that area I renovate a house we move
in
there I borrow $35 million and I'm
buying houses now I'm buying houses
recording the value I start all over you
know I borrow like whatever $35 million
I meet aanda we move in together uh
we're we're we're buying do you tell her
do you tell her about she kind of you
know what she knew was that you know
it's it's it's odd right I have no
photographs everything I own is brand
new she's like you don't there's nothing
in this house that's more than four
months old so 6 months old you have no
photographs you have no internet
presence you have no you know it's every
stick of clothing is brand new you don't
have old pairs of jeans do do you tell
their stories about the past of any like
is there a
fabricated the init initially there was
a fabricated version that I owned a I
owned a mortgage
company um my typical story was like I
own a mortgage company and I got bought
out by Household Bank started doing very
well I got bought out by Household Bank
I have a no non-compete Clause I got you
know I ended up with like half a million
dollars after paying off all my bills uh
and just decided to kind of travel
around the the US and now I'm here I'm
going to start renovating
houses but that you know you don't call
home nobody calls you your family
doesn't call you you tell stories about
your mom your dad your brother your
sister friends I don't know any of these
friends never seen any of these friends
they never call you they never you know
it's just like it's like ah so at
some point I basically just said to her
look I'm list at one point I had to have
a check cut I refinanced the house right
and I had like I want to say I'm G to
say something like it might have been
30,000 but let's say 20,000 I had a
$20,000 check cut to Amanda Garder cuz
you have to have these checks you can't
have them cut to me so I would say hey
there's a second mortgage on there and
i' provide a second mortgage or I'd
provide you know I provide different
things and I knew if I I need names of
people to cut these things to so I had a
check cut for whatever so I remember
we're at dinner one night this is before
she really knows who I am and I said hey
uh I said oh and she goes oh did you had
a refine she goes how'd that thing go
you're refinance I would oh thank God
you said that boom I said I need you to
deposit this give check for 20,000 she's
like um I can I can I can go tomorrow
and and I can deposit it and I um um and
I'm like no no I'm like look it's fine
just deposit it I can get as soon as it
clears I I I'll get you a cashier check
um I was like No just deposit it and
keep it in your bank it's fine so she's
like what is going on you know and so we
have this conversation and I tell her
look people are looking for me who law
enforcement which ones all of them you
know she's like that doesn't even wa for
what I
go mostly bank fraud and she's like well
how are they not finding you MH I mean
everybody you know people know you like
you know your general contractor which I
met four months before this guy six
months before this one two months before
you know she's like so and so so and so
so and I'm like right right well I said
well she's like I mean they've got your
name they've got your I go well that's
identity theft and she was like what do
you mean I said well my name's not you
know my name's not it's not Joseph
Carter and what is your what is your
name I go look you know it's it's you
don't need don't even worry about it
this is what's happening this is where
I'm at this has been months into the
relationship I mean this is or i' say
maybe a month or two in but you know she
was just too inquisitive and oh I know
what it was she found like $40,000 in
cash in my freezer one night that was
another thing that happened she went to
get a popsicle and she opened up the the
flip to get a popsicle and she opened
the wrong one and it was all cash and
she was like like you know I the other
day you know in this conversation like
the other day I opened up the popsicle
box and there's cash and I'm like so I
kind of explain it but I had a feeling
she's not going to she's going to be
okay with this you know so she was okay
she was okay with this I mean to me
that's just a fascinating conversation
to have like it was a great conversation
CU often times in relationships you
learn about each other and you find out
new things and here you find out y yeah
it's a good one to find
out the name you're using is not your
real name and the Secret Service the FBI
and everybody else are looking for you
yeah and you're like to be honest you're
not a violent criminal so it's like and
I you know you know but she didn't know
my name like she was like
she and I told her I said look if you
start digging if you find out my name
like I'll leave like there's certain
things that catch you staying in contact
with people that you know that's how you
get caught you know going back to see
people that's how you get caught you
know um telling people who you are
that's how you get caught and I was like
so I'm Joseph
Carter everything's fine and she was
like okay you know and keep in mind too
this girl do you oh your car's broken or
your car's not doing well take it and
trade it in we'll go get you another car
we'll go get you you know an Infinity
you know FX or whatever you know a
$55,000 $60,000 vehicle she's
driving the equivalent of a a beat up
old Nova you know I mean it's you want
to go on vacation we'll go on vacation
you want to do this you want to do that
so you know we're buying houses I I'm
we're we're renovating houses we're
we're building brand new houses we're
buying Lots like she's like in the
middle of this like holy Jesus there's
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
bank in our bank account uh her bank
account I open up a corporation in her
name she opening up bank accounts she's
got web there's websites it's it's a lot
and while this is
happening we start seeing a a a friend
of hers so this other girl comes in the
picture her name's Trina and um Trina is
um semi lesbian
so is it is like a sexual thing yeah or
actual relationship no it's no it's more
like uh she's coming over a couple times
a week okay so we've got a ton of tons
going
on uh
and let put this so while this is
happening I I end up coming out in like
several magazines so I'm thinking this
whole thing's dying down but it's not
dying down because now I just got caught
and handcuffed in a bank walked out of
the police station outran Marshals
although that that part the Marshall
thing never was never in the papers
but um the getting caught and handcuffed
in the bank when that hit the papers
that's everywhere bro that's huge you
know suddenly Chicago tribunes running a
series The fugitives um I'm in Bloomberg
business week they run an articles
article called you know sharks in the
housing pool uh then you've got a
Fortune Magazine comes out with a thing
because by now guess what Becky's been
caught oh Becky Becky
back is she in Houston or whatever in
Houston got caught and did she but
gangster bro like the way she here's the
thing hey there you go no oh no she told
on me immediately oh she did oh no it's
fine she do the right thing so here
here's what's funny about that I don't
know about that she here's what she says
loyalty is everything in this world my
friend that you and I disagree on I just
took off I just took off still on her
and left her with with with listen with
like six or like5 or $600,000 is what I
left her with it's not it's not all
about money Matthew it's also about just
like you know ride or die there's a
meaning to that my God I'm sorry go
ahead she told she said everything well
here's what was when I say gangster when
she gets caught yeah um they come in
she's in the middle of beauty school
she's paid for beauty school she's going
through beauty school she's going to
open like a salon or something so she's
in there cutting hair in a class you
know on a man and all of a sudden like
five or six uh Secret Service agents
come in guns drawn screaming get on the
ground get on the ground she said
everybody dropped to the ground she said
I'm sitting there with scissors
going you know they grab her they
handcuff her they bring her in and the
whole time now at that point she was
Rebecca well she was yeah her name was
Rebecca hickey she went by Becca she so
she's Rebecca hickey which is you know
it's she's got a Texas driver's license
the whole thing and they're screaming at
her and they she they put her in the car
and they're driving the whole way she
goes the guy the secret service agent
told me 45 minutes she's telling us
you're losing your job bro you're losing
I mean he he's like I I couldn't believe
it like we we got pictures of her we're
like this is you she's like that's not
me are you insane look at that chubby
little thing Jes would not budge till
they actually put her hand on the
scanner and she goes okay I'm I'm
Rebecca Hal what do you need
they're like where's Matt Cox she's I
have no idea that left me like a
year ago
so um so but she contributed to the
story to the legend that's already
growing oh oh because she was
interviewed by uh Fortune Magazine and
it was horrendous the article is
horrendous he was abusive he he's a Don
Juan that that forced me to fall in love
with him commit mortgage fraud and then
took all the money and left by the way
they found like 40 or 50 Grand on her
and maybe another 30 or 40 in her bank
account and no other
money yeah where's the other money um so
anyway and she was by the way she got
caught she was in communication with her
family so she's talking to her mom
that's when she got caught timately and
her mother through multiple
conversations one conversation being Mom
I'm doing fine I'm I can't tell you
where I am you know exactly but I I'm in
Houston Texas I'm fine next one 6 months
later I enrolled in Beauty School
Houston Texas Beauty School how many are
there Y and her mom bipolar I just want
to see my daughter yeah I'm going to
call the Secret Service yep I'm doing
the right thing yeah and and honestly
she is doing the right thing so
um
that